[Music]
you know ken we have a venn diagram and
my world is you know it's money stuff
and your world is career but also you
love sports
and so today the venn diagram finally
meets in the middle
because we have an article here that is
connecting the sports world to the money
world oh you ready for this oh this is
fascinating i'm very excited here's the
headline from
firstsports.com with a z take take that
with a grain of salt again here's the
folks you'd be very gentle with george
because he's entering into completely
unknown territory right now if i biff
some sports names please i'm here for
you all right here's the headline okay
quote bad investment odell beckham jr's
750 000 contract just worth over 35 000
after bitcoin plummets
well so that tells me he had a contract
that was bitcoin infused he signed a
one-year deal with the rams that can pay
him up to 4.25 million dollars with the
majority of the deal being heavily based
upon incentives and uh it was ultimately
a one-year 1.25 million dollar deal with
a 750 base salary 750 how much of that
was bitcoin
um it looks like the 750. wow that was a
bad move obj here's what it's saying
obj people call him obj in this football
world this helps me out okay immensely i
didn't want to confuse you uh but yeah
it says uh beckham took his salary in
bitcoin oh that's he took to twitter to
announce his bold move to take salary
and crypto yeah sure he said it's the
start of a new era i'm looking forward
to the future
however obj's move just backfired
because according to sports business
analyst darren rovell did i get that
right yeah very good very good the
beckham contract is only worth four
hundred and twelve thousand nine hundred
and fifty three dollars here's the sad
news after factoring in the taxes which
is based on the original amount obj will
be left with just over thirty five
thousand dollars so he only got a bit of
that contract i see what you did there
he'll be here all week folks the dad
jokes come out of me every once in a
while folks i apologize
james is one more dad joke away from
muting you okay be nice james i
apologize but it was kind of relevant
bitcoin bit of his contract i loved it
son ford thank you very much now uh
this is happening across the board we
can pick on obj so you're a big crypto
uh you follow this you follow the news
you're a bit of a uh you're what would i
call you you're a bit of a a crypto
uh crypto curious yes you're a crypto
curious yes well
i get questions about this a lot from
our fans from our audience going hey is
this a good idea i saw this what
so i've had to look into it we did an
episode on the fine print all about
cryptocurrency and bitcoin and here's
the thing i'm not mad at bitcoin every
time we talk about cryptocurrency the
crypto bros come at us and they're angry
because we don't understand and it's the
future and the blockchain is the
technology's amazing seems like a scary
bunch
they are very the crypto bros i will say
this they make the mlm folks look soft
and that is saying something wow
multi-level marketing yeah
georgia's firing i don't want your
tupperware okay i got plenty of it uh so
is it because the reason that this is so
scary is because it is so wildly uh
speculative in that it's volatile up
down and so you know it's down 60
percent yeah it keeps crashing down and
listen it'll it'll probably go back up
but then it's going to crash immensely
and this roller coaster it doesn't have
the proven traffic i tell you one of the
problems george you got matt damon
you got matt damon telling me
that i'm that i'm not brave if i don't
jump into this be brave i'm watching him
he's talking about the fortune favors
the brave and i'm sitting there on the
couch watching i love goodwill hunting
as much as the next guy but see
celebrities pitching crypto this is my
point and even the media outlets can
have been going after the celebrities
because
there's no recourse for this celebrities
are just blindly endorsing crypto for
oodles of money and then when crypto
crashes the celebrities aren't out there
saying sorry
i was wrong yeah
so this is a big problem we're not anti
cryptocurrency we're just saying this is
not a smart financial move right now
given the the fact that it is is
relatively uh brand new i mean this is
still in its infancy if you will and uh
regulations and the fact that it's not
recognized across the board you know a
lot of stuff here be careful be very
careful especially if you are a pro
athlete listening which i'm sure there's
so many out there wow i mean if dave
said hey ken i'm going to start paying
you in bitcoin now hell would have to
freeze over for that to happen yeah but
if that happened i'll go no i'll take
i'll take money i'll take real
dollars in my bank account i think my
first reaction would be what did obj do
no i'm kidding there we go hey this is
very exciting we got to talk about
bitcoin and you learned who odell
beckham jr is which is fantastic
usually i learned something you learned
something this is great all of my sports
knowledge comes from the original space
jam movie ken as you know so in my mind
patrick ewing is still hot on the courts
yeah we were actually talking about this
uh pre-show today and we were we said we
were going to talk about this and george
says well ken i need you to pipe in
because i don't know much about sports
players
i want to leave that with the audience
that's what they're called not all of
them are athletes i mean have you seen
soccer sports they're actors not
athletes i went to my first soccer game
you're gonna offend a lot of people
soccer is a
worldwide sport
that's careful george i'm just saying i
went to the nashville soccer club game
and it was there was a lot of did you
sing and yell with the group the whole
time they were all yelling different
things profanities and such i'm not
going to be involved in that i i have
class i do love the vu vezuela you know
that is that how you say it yeah i think
it's called vue vezuela if i'm saying
that correctly yeah that noise alone oh
i love his way that's reason to never go
to say it
i just said it three times in 10 seconds
i'm hearing vavuzela is the
is it vavuzela
all right we'll look it up we'll get to
the calls we'll come back with that for
the three people who are still listening
to the show uh thank you for joining us
we're going to take a call now